hello from the afterlife
more specifically hell I know I was as
surprised as you
I didn't even realize it when I first
got here because it was not any
different from Pakistan it only hit me
when I saw Niro accusing Karl Marx of
cheating at pick-up sticks
Satan notified me that it was a Navy
SEAL who taken me out in my Pakistani
compound and that my death was kind of a
big deal please pay no mind to the
pictures in the news if I'd have known
that I'd be having company I would have
cleaned up
speaking of Satan he is not what I
expected he kind of looks like a Brendan
Fraser and a young Walter Matthau had a
baby now I am sure many of you want to
know what hell is like and so I am
reminded of a joke
a man is sent to hell Satan comes up to
women says welcome the man says this is
not what I expected
this place is rather nice Satan says yes
we have been given a bad rap up there
let me ask you do you like to gamble
the man says of course that's how I lost
my first wife was gambling and a problem
Satan says oh you're going to love
Mondays we have the best casino in the
world with high rollers cocktails and
great gambling do you like eating great
food the man says
yes that's how I died I was obese from
eating too much Satan says oh you're
going to love Tuesdays we have best
chefs put together a huge buffet and
just indulge in gluttony
it's great hey do you like being
brutally pummeled and exploited by
throngs of large angry men without mercy
the man says no of course not
Satan pauses oh well you're going to
hate Wednesdays this is not a joke
anymore I really do hate Wednesdays they
are the worst by a landslide I am still
sore even worse
all we have for entertainment is the
Black Eyed Peas greatest hits and post
mall rats Kevin Smith movies you try
watching Jersey girl knowing that you
cannot kill yourself I almost forgot to
Nancy Pelosi
Satan says that he needs another case a
product - zero zero four nine eight
seven - and if you could expedite it
that would be great now some people say
it was Barack Obama who took me out some
say George W Bush most say United States
military I blame that damn courier in
his flashy tennis shoes I told him not
to wear the Nike Shox and we paid for it
anyway I suppose you could say that I've
made my bed and that I should lie in it
only here we sleep in bits looking back
making my life's focus bringing death to
America probably not my best decision as
far as regrets it ranks right up there
with endorse John Kerry in 2004 I am
being given the signal now that it's
time to wrap it up as I have a back
waxing scheduled with Colleen and please
if someone could tell me who wins this
season of American Idol it will be
greatly appreciated text I still can't
believe that they let Casey go what a
talented kid